نعود الان الى الخبر العاجل الذي نوهنا
عنه قبل قليل عن دوي اربع انفجارات قويه
شرقي العاصمه العراقيه بغداد مصادر امنيه
عراقيه تقول الجزيره ان القصف في بغداد هو
استهداف لمركبه يشتبه انها تقل شخصيه في
الفصائل
العراقيه طياره مسيره
وضرب ها طرب الف عافيه مستهدفين سيااره
صواريخ استه
ومعنا الان مباشره من بغداد مراسلنا عامر
لافي عامر ماذا نعرف عن هذه الشخصيه التي
استهدفت
وتفاصيل اكثر بشان ما جرى وهذا التفجير
الذي
حصل نعم ليلى لا يوجد طبعا تفاصيل وافيه
حتى الان لكن ما وصلنا من مصادر امنيه ان
سياره يفترض ربما انها تابعه للحشد الشعبي
يوجد فيها ثلاث ركاب الاخبار التي وصلتنا
حتى الان تتحدث عن احتمال مقتل هؤلاء
الثلاثه الذين كانوا يستقلون هذه السياره
في حي المشتل في اقصى شرق بغداد في طرف
الرصاصه من بغداد اي القصف تم بواسطه
ثلاثه صواريخ يفترض ايضا حسب ما وصلنا من
معلومات من مصادر امنيه هذا القصف تم
بواسطه مسيرات مسيره استهدفت هذه السياره
الان الشرطه العراقيه تفرض طوقا امنيا حول
هذا المكان الدفاع المدني وصل الى هذا
المكان وبدا با باخماد النار وتمكن كما
فهمنا حتى الان من اخماد الحرائق التي
اندلعت اثر استهداف هذه السياره المعلومه
التي نحاول التاكد منها ليلى الان وهي
الاهم هي هل صحيح ان الثلاثه الذين كانوا
في السياره قد قتلوا وما هي هويه هؤلاء
الثلاثه طبعا المهم هنا ان نشير الى انه
كان هناك نوع من التخمين والت وقع بان
ربما لا نريد السباق الامور لكن المرحله
الثانيه من الاستهداف الامريكي والرد
الامريكي على قتل الجنود الثلاثه كما كان
يتداول هنا من المحللين والمراقبين ان
المرحله الثانيه لن تكون بقوه المرحله
الاولى ولكن ستكون عباره عن عمليات
انتقائيه لاغتيال شخصيات معينه وربما في
هذا الاطار اذا وضعنا الصوره الكبيره
العامه يمكن ان نفهم ان هذه هي المرحله
الثانيه التي كما قلنا ربما محاوله
لاغتيال شخصيات بارزه تتهمها الولايات
المتحده بانها تقف خلف العمليات التي من
خلالها تستهدف المقاومه الاسلاميه هنا في
العراق القواعد الامريكيه سواء كما تعلمين
في العراق او في داخل سوريا تعلمين ان
البنتاجون كان قد تحدث في اخر تصريح له عن
161 استهدافا لهذه المواقع والقواعد
العسكريه في داخل العراق وفي سوريا بعد
الضربات التي وجهها الى مناطق غرب العراق
وتحديدا في القائم وفي العكاشات التي قتل
اثرها 16 من جنود ومنتسبي الحشد الشعبي
كثير من فصائل المقاومه العراقيه تحدثت عن
انها لن توقف العمليات العسكريه واستهداف
القواعد الامريكيه حتى تنسحب القوات
الامريكيه من داخل العراق وحتى تتوقف
الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه وبالفعل
هذا ما جرى يعني بعد استهداف كان هناك عده
عمليات استهدفت من خلالها قاعده حرير في
اربيل القريبه من مطار اربيل ايضا استهدفت
عين الاسد واستهدفت عده قواعد ايضا
امريكيه في داخل سوريا وبالتالي استمرت
هذه العمليات ولم تتوقف تعلمين الولايات
المتحده كما يعني قالت بان الهدف من هذه
العمليات هي وضع حد العمليات اعني
الاستهداف الذي طال مواقع الحشد الشعبي
كان الهدف منه ان توقف العمليات لكن فصائل
المقاومه قالت بانها لن توقفها وهو ما حدث
وعلى ما يبدو اذا فهمنا هذا ولا نريد طبعا
ان نسترق الامور لكن الصوره الان الواضحه
امامنا انه على ما يبدو من خلال ايضا
العديد من المصات القريبه من الحشد الشعبي
والمقاومه الاسلاميه تتهم الولايات
المتحده بالوقوف وراء هذا الاستهداف وتقول
بان هذه المسيرات هي مسيرات امريكيه
استهدفت هذه السياره السياره كانت في حاله
حركه في هذه المنطقه في اقصى شرق بغداد
كما قلنا والحديث والذي نحاول التاكد منه
كما ذكرت لك هل بالفعل قتل الثلاثه الذين
كانوا على متنها ومن هم هذه الشخصيات التي
استهدفت في قلب العاصمه بغداد نعلم انه
يعني في الاستهداف الاول منطقه في اقصى
غرب العراق على الحدود مع سوريا وبالتالي
كان الحديث عن استهداف بعيد عن قلب العراق
وكان الحديث عن انه قد لا تلجا الولايات
المتحده ل
تنفيذ ضربات في داخل بغداد لكن على ما
يبدو اذا صح ان الولايات المتحده هي التي
تقف وراء هذه العمليه فاذا الولايات
المتحده قررت ان تضرب في بغداد كما ذكرنا
وكما كان توقع كثير من المراقبين كمرحله
ثانيه استهداف شخصيات عمليات دعينا نصفها
كما قالوا او كما وصفوها بالجراح لاستهداف
واغتيال شخصيات
بعينها